We start with this
severe weather on the West Coast,
because right now,
8 million people across
the Southwest
are at risk of dangerous
flash flooding after Tropical Storm
Hillary unleashed
record shattering
rainfall and catastrophic floods
in southern California.
It turned desert towns into rivers.
Take a look at this new video
in to CNN of Cathedral City
being overtaken by floodwaters overnight.
Hillary has weakened
to a post tropical cyclone threat.
Not over yet, though,
forecasters are warning
there could be more mudslides,
more life
threatening flooding all day there.
This was the scene in San
Bernardino County.
You can see trees and boulders
just rushing by up in the mountains.
Firefighters
were trapped at their station after
look at this
huge mudslide blocked the road.
They heard a rumbling noise
and they went to check it out.
And then one of the firefighters
was recording this video
when a wall of mud and rocks,
they started coming down the hill
towards them
and they had to run for safety.
We have team coverage.
Derek Van
Dam is tracking the storm
in the CNN Weather Center
as the latest on the forecast.
Mike Valerio is in San Diego.
Let's start, though,
with Stephanie
Elam live on the ground
in Cathedral City.
You've been there all day
and now overnight into the morning.
What are you seeing
It's still water on the roads.
Oh, so much water.
Victor, take a look down here
because I'm actually standing
next to the edge of the curb here
and I try to put my toe down
to feel like how far down that is
and I can't reach it.
That's how deep it is.
And since last time I talked to you
an hour ago, there was a car here.
They finally got a tow truck.
It took them about four or 5 hours
before the tow truck could get here.
This is happening
all through these desert towns
because it was just so much water
in such a short amount of time.
This morning,
Palm Springs is under a local emergency
order
as heavy rain from Hillary
is causing dangerous flood conditions.
And prompting at least three
swift water rescues.
We're asking residents
to stay inside, stay where they are.
The mayor's warning
is because of a situation like this.
A pickup truck stuck
in the middle of a street
surrounded by deep rushing floodwaters.
The driver was not injured,
but the California Highway Patrol
closed the road
to prevent others
from crossing those floodwaters.
So powerful.
A refrigerator
was seen floating away in them.
This drone video
taken over a nearby neighborhood
where the flooding has nearly covered
an entire golf course.
One homeowner
says he's never seen anything like it
in the Coachella Valley.
Within 24 hours, it's
turned into a torrential storm
between total number 13
and whole number 16.
It's virtually six feet thick.
The conditions there
also creating a dangerous situation
for drivers,
including a fire truck
forced to turn around
due to rising waters ahead of the storm.
The Palm Springs
mayor says the city prepared
and distributed
60,000 sandbags
as well as cleared storm drains.
The even
an inch or two of rain in the desert
can cause damage.
All right. Take a look at this.
The road totally covered up,
but it's also completely socked in
on this other side
of the road.
I mean, look
who is barely touching the bottom there.
State officials say some desert regions
like Palm Springs
could double their yearly amount of water
in just one day from Hillary.
Overnight, officials in Ventura County
searched by helicopter
and on the ground
for a couple of people
believed to be trapped by floodwaters
from the Santa Clara River.
Two people
eventually walked out of the flooded area
assisted by cruise officials
urging everyone
to stay out of river
bottoms and canals were
and this was the scene
Sunday in Wrightwood,
about 77 miles northeast of Los Angeles.
Huge gushes of water, forcing their way
through a wash
carrying large logs,
rock and muddy debris.
Exactly the type of thing
the governor wants
people to be on alert for.
Take seriously debris flows and floods.
Flash floods, lightning
possibility of tornadoes,
And we were out here
all day yesterday
while the storm really made its impact
felt here.
And it was amazing to see
just how quickly roads were flooded out.
It was happening so fast.
So no surprise today
that some schools are closed.
Many schools in this region are closed
today.
And also,
what we're also hearing is that 911
communications are down.
And that is why
it is still taking a long time
for rescuers to go out
because so many of the roads
are inundated,
including Interstate ten,
which runs through here as well,
Poppy and Victor.
Wow. 911 down in some areas.
Makes it even worse.
Jeff, thank you very much.
Later this hour, we're going to be joined
by the mayor of Palm
Springs, California, Mayor Grace Garner
from Southern California.
Out to the CNN Weather Center.
Meteorologist Derek
Van Dam is there tracking the system.
So, Derek, we saw the wake.
What's ahead?
Yes.
So much rain, right?
National Weather
Service out of Los Angeles
is just tweeting a few minutes ago
that virtually
all of their observation sites
have broken daily record rainfall.
That's incredible.
And we still have a few hours to go
coming out of Los Angeles.
Some rainfall moving into that area.
And, of course,
the system
is just
bulleting to the north
at about 30 miles per hour.
And we wanted to highlight
some of the lesser
impressive rainfall totals.
But they are impressive
because they're breaking daily
rainfall records.
But also, it's
never rain
this much in the month of August.
Keep in mind,
this is generally a dry area
for this time of year.
San Diego
their wettest day in nearly six years.
Long Beach
and Los Angeles also
setting daily record rainfall rates.
Rainfall totals,
I should say, from yesterday
this is in the past 24 hours.
7 million Americans or 8 million actually
currently under flash flood warning.
This includes portions of Los
Angeles County.
I want to highlight this area
because we have the transverse range.
This is a mountain range
located across Southern California.
And this water has literally
been piling up across this area,
just the rainfall
kind of bands
just working in perpendicular
to this mountain range.
So basically all of it
funneling down
the canyons below
and unfortunately producing
that mudflows,
debris slides and landslides
that we're seeing on our TV screens
this morning.
A lot of rain moving up the West Coast.
This is going to continue
for the next 12 hours. Wow.
Thank you, Derek.
We know you'll watch it. Thanks so much.
All right.
Let's go to our colleague,
Michael Ilario.
He's live in San Diego
for us in Southern California
this morning.
Good morning, Mike.
A lot of flooding from the mountains
and the deserts, all the way to the coast
Well, Poppy
and Phil, good morning to you.
And that's exactly where
we're going to start here on the coast,
just up the street
where we are in San Diego.
So overnight,
there are no fewer than nine
people, Poppy and Phil,
who were rescued by San Diego
fire personnel.
This was an encampment
of people experiencing homelessness
who thought that
they could ride out this storm
on an island
in the middle of the San Diego River.
If you're familiar with the area.
Pretty close to SeaWorld,
pretty close to Mission Bay.
All of them are okay.
But because the flooding threat
isn't over in our inland
to coastal streams and rivers,
there are no fewer than Ten River
search and rescue teams
that San Diego fire
is putting up and down
the river from Mission Bay
all the way to the five,
which is a pretty long stretch
of the San Diego River.
But I think Poppy and Phil
just you know, it's
very early here in San Diego,
but traversing the streets,
there is very little damage,
thankfully, to the infrastructure here.
I think preparation was key
from lessons
learned in January, February and March
when we had that
a succession
of atmospheric rivers coming through.
But Mayor Todd
Gloria of San Diego
made it a point to say
that he was
mobilizing hundreds
of extra
emergency workers
because this is not
what San Diego is used to.
Listen, to what he told us
We're not used to this
level of precipitation generally.
Certainly not in the middle of summer
in August.
We're not built
for this kind of rainfall.
That's my main concern.
But with what we're expecting,
it may overwhelm us and we will.
We're asking the public
to stay out of those
areas for your safety
and the safety of our first responders.
So as we're
looking out across the bay,
you're going to see
very faintly that number.
72, that is the USS Abraham Lincoln
talking about preparations In the U.S.
Navy has sent out
ten ships from the Third Fleet
just to minimize ship
overcrowding
because the waters were very choppy here.
So preparation was key
damage minimal in the city of San Diego.
This is the wettest
weather event for
San Diego since 1873 when President Grant
was in the White House.
So certainly a bullet dodged.
Victor and Poppy Victor.
Very sorry.
It's before the crack of dawn.
So we will certainly wait
until the sun comes up
to assess the rest of the damage.
But it seems as though
our friends in the desert communities
have faced the brunt of this storm
and have the worst of the damage.